deborah messing apparently doesn't keep
up with kim kardashian why not
well we'll tell you after saturday night
live announced wednesday that the
reality star is set to make her hosting
debut on october 9th deborah who has
never hosted the show before
shaded kim on twitter writing why kim
kardashian i mean i know she's a
cultural icon but snl has hosts
generally who are performers who are
there to promote a film tv show or album
launch am i missing something yes
some fans on social media think the will
and grace star isn't up to speed on
kim's resume with one user writing truth
be told deborah messing kim kardashian
just wrapped up what is likely the most
successful and longest-running reality
television show in history and is
launching a new series on hulu that and
her side gigs skims and kkw beauty made
her a billionaire she is nbc snl worthy
people are going to make judgments so i
think i beat people to the punch as for
kim she's excited about the big gig
sharing the news on her instagram story
wednesday and gushing omfg no turning
back now lol i'm hosting snl it's really
lit and fun and crazy the nbc series
announced that the skim's founder would
be one of the show's first four hosts of
the season during kim's hosting duties
halsey will serve as the musical guest
that's so cool a source is also opening
up to et about kim's snl debut
explaining quote kim is very excited to
host snl and plans to poke fun at
herself in the family she has a great
sense of humor and the mother of four is
already prepping for her big live moment
i'm definitely taking my time the source
adds kim takes everything she does very
seriously and has a lot of famous
comedian friends she can lean on for
help so blessed to have the best support
system and let's not forget kim recently
dipped her toe in the world of movies
when she took on the animated role of
dolores in the paw patrol movie huh
please this scrawny little purse pup is
gonna pull a jailbreak the kkw beauty
founder gave a little speech at a
private screening explaining why the
project was meaningful to her
okay guys i want to welcome everyone
here to the paw patrol movie i'm so
excited that i get to show all my kids
and all the cousins and all my friends
and everyone
my first movie this year
[Applause]
[Music]
i know i have but this is different this
is like an animated movie this is so
cool i did this for you guys
because i know that how much you've
always loved paw patrol and i'm so
excited
all right so let's start the movie guys
[Music]